[Musik]
gipfel der enttäuschung bei der
klimakonferenz in madrid einigt sich die
welt lediglich auf einen mini kompromiss
neue züge billigere tickets mit dem
fahrplanwechsel will die bahn ab heute
mehr kunden locken und biathlon krimi
für die deutsche staffel beim weltcup in
hochfilzen verpassen die männer den sieg
nur um zwei sekunden
nachrichten des tages heute mit
christian sievers meine damen und herren
guten abend hinein und herzlich
willkommen bei uns um 7 norbert hat den
sport im blick natürlich genannt aber
wir beginnen mit dem ringen um das
weltklima gruseliger phil staat das
sagen umweltorganisationen über das
ergebnis der weltklimakonferenz
denn die hat trotz rekord länge und
weltweiter klima- proteste gerade mal
einen minimalkompromiss gebracht gucken
wir uns das mal genauer an
geeinigt haben sich die gipfelstaaten
nur auf einen appell mehr co2
einzusparen konkrete regeln dazu gibt es
aber nicht
und eine entscheidung zum
emissionshandel wurde verschoben das war
eigentlich eines der hauptziele der
konferenz der handel soll die
verschmutzer dazu bringen in
umweltfreundliche technologien zu
investieren so bleibt nach madrid vor
allem eins große enttäuschung bei den
meisten anna maria schuck jetzt über
eine konferenz mit minimalergebnis 13
verhandlungstage und 40 stunden
verlängerung noch nie hat eine
weltklimakonferenz so lange gedauert und
trotzdem es ist ganz klar die beschlüsse
die wir heute erzielt haben reichen
nicht aus deshalb sind wir auch nicht
zufrieden
damit werden wir der dringlichkeit der
klimakrise nicht gericht noch am morgen
wollten länder wie brasilien
nachverhandeln die jetzige bilanz
ernüchternd
in der gemeinsamen abschlusserklärung
werden alle staaten lediglich an ihre
zusage erinnert im nächsten jahr ihre
klimaschutzziele für 2030 zu verschärfen
wir haben den eindruck dass hier einige
länder einen kampf gegen den
multilateralismus also gegen die
zusammenarbeit von staaten führen weil
sie nicht daran glauben sondern weil sie
nur an nationale interessen glauben und
dass sie dabei vergessen dass in einer
welt in der probleme global werden wie
eben die erhitzung dass es da keine
nationalen lösungen gibt bei dem
wichtigsten thema wurde gar keine
einigung erzielt den klimaschutz
zertifikaten die nachweisen wollen dass
länder auch wirklich treibhausgase
eingespart haben
die klimakrise verlangt deutlich mehr
und die tatsache dass wir hier zwei tage
mehr verhandeln mussten zeigt dass doch
noch so einiges abzuarbeiten ist
schwierige aufgaben also für die
kommenden monate bis zur nächsten
un-klimakonferenz in glasgow und dazu
jetzt die einschätzung von volker angres
aus unserer umwelt redaktion der nach
vorn guckt es ist wie ein letztes
aufbäumen der länder die nach wie vor
massiv von der öl und kohle lobby
beherrscht werden die heftigen
diskussionen hier haben nicht nur die
konferenz präsidentschaft überrascht
das pariser abkommen zum klimaschutz
aber hat die schlacht überlebt die
ergebnisse hier sind gerade noch
hinnehmbar
die nächste klimakonferenz in glasgow
allerdings die wird hart denn dann
müssen turnusgemäß alle länder strengere
klimaschutzziele vorlegen sagt volker
angres die daten der wissenschaftler
zeigen wie dringend es wäre etwas gegen
die erwärmung des erdklimas zu tun
alle zahlen und fakten dazu zum
nachlesen finden sie in einem überblick
auf heute de und in der heute
vergleichsweise gut fürs klima ist
bahnfahren aber auch da gibt es ja in
deutschland massiv probleme
der fahrplanwechsel bei der bahn heute
soll einiges richten erst mal saß aber
auch die klimaaktivisten greta thonberg
in einem überfüllten ic e auf dem boden
zumindest für einen teil der strecke von
der klimakonferenz in madrid nach
schweden und hat das auf twitter kund
getan
die bahn fühlte sich herausgefordert und
verwies unter anderem darauf dass sie an
mehr zügen verbindungen und sitzplätzen
arbeite wie das konkret ab heute laufen
soll mit dem neuen fahrplan zeigt hans
jürgen thiel die neueste zugverbindung
der deutschen bahn
im intercity zehnmal täglich von dresden
nach rostock wo bisher nur
regionalbahnen fuhren mit
fahrplanwechsel wird es im letzte db
nicht nur die neue verbindung an die
ostsee geben weil in münchen soll einen
loosen stunden tag bekommen und auch auf
anderen wichtigen fernstrecken will die
bahn mehr züge einsetzen
vor allem aber sollen auch fahrscheine
im neuen jahr statt 19 nur noch sieben
prozent mehrwertsteuer fällig werden
voraussetzung das klimapaket dessen
bestandteil die regelung ist wird noch
in der kommenden woche verabschiedet wir
werden alle fahrpreise und wirklich alle
fahrpreise durch die bank um zehn
prozent absenken das heißt denn es wird
für den fahrgast viel viel günstiger mit
der bahn zu verreisen das wird noch
leichter gemacht vom auto den zug
umzusteigen
doch kritiker bezweifeln dass allein
günstigere tickets mehr menschen in die
züge locken werden sie raten auf teile
der preissenkung zu verzichten und
stattdessen in verbesserte angebote zu
investieren
niedrigere preise im fernverkehr sind
ein wichtiger schritt um mehr fahrgäste
zu gewinnen
aber das allein wird nicht ausreichen
was es braucht ist vor allem besseres
angebot mehr züge die auf den schienen
unterwegs
doch egal wann die mehrwertsteuer
änderung kommt auf eine fahrpreis
senkung ab januar als sich die bahn
bereits festgelegt super sparpreis
tickets werden dann statt 19 euro 90 nur
noch 17 90 kosten
in der deutschen innenpolitik heute
drängt bundesarbeitsminister hubertus
heil darauf die grundrente möglichst
schnell auf den weg zu bringen
beschlossen werden soll das gesetz im
januar die grundrente so ein wichtiger
beitrag für die bekämpfung von
altersarmut besonders frauen
profitierten davon sagt heil
die cdu hatte klar gemacht dass die
grundrente nur dann kommen wenn die spd
in der großen koalition bleibt
wieder hat eine reihe von erdbeben den
süden der philippinen erschüttert dabei
erreichten die schwersten erdstöße eine
stärke von 6,8 mindestens vier menschen
kamen ums leben einige sollen
verschüttet oder verletzt sein
die philippinen liegen auf einem
vulkangürtel seit monaten gibt es dort
immer wieder heftige beben bei protesten
gegen die regierung im libanon sind mehr
als 100 menschen verletzt worden
einige demonstranten hatten gestern
abend in der hauptstadt beirut versucht
zum parlamentsgebäude vorzudringen
die polizei setzte schlagstöcke und viel
tränengas ein
im libanon protestieren die menschen
seit wochen gegen misswirtschaft und
korruption
und damit sind wir an diesem sonntag
beim sport norbert und dass wir deine
aufgaben ja genau die überschrift des
sonntags heißt sie können es doch noch
und das freut die biathlon fans zum
abschluss der weitgehend enttäuschenden
weltcup tage in hochfilzen liefert das
deutsche männer-quartett eine beinahe
blitzsaubere vorstellung und landet auf
platz zwei knapp hinter weltmeister
norwegen
so sieht jemand aus der sich auf der
schlussrunde vollkommen verausgabt hat
benedikt doll deutschlands schlussläufer
beim letzten schießen zunächst klar im
vorteil doch dann zeigt der
sprintweltmeister von 2017 nerven muss
zweimal nachladen
er geht zwar als erster zurück auf die
schlussrunde doch der norweger johannes
knispel kommt immer näher
er hat einfach die fähigkeit zu sagen
naja ich laufe jetzt einfach schneller
dass die lücke zu geht auf der
zielgeraden die attacke soll muss sich
geschlagen geben nachdem der vorsprung
des norwegers nur zwei sekunden
für die deutschen männer ist dieser
zweite platz ein versöhnlicher abschluss
hier in hochfilzen auf rang drei die
staffel aus frankreich gastgeber denn
lecker woche im ersten sonntagsspiel der
fußball-bundesliga verpasst borussia
mönchengladbach die rückkehr an die
tabellenspitze gladbach unterliegt in
wolfsburg mit 1 zu 2 durch ein tor von
maximilian arnold in der nachspielzeit
damit bleibt leipzig tabellenführer zwei
punkte vor den borussen
alle jahre wieder kurz vor weihnachten
erfahren sie bei uns im zdf wer
deutschlands sportlerin sportler und
mannschaft des jahres geworden sind um
22.15 geht's los
kathrin müller hohenstein und rudi cerne
im kurhaus baden-baden ihr seid
startklar
alle gäste schon an bord also wir
könnten sofort anfangen norbert okay wer
schmeißt uns natürlich noch richtig
internat aber dann die prominenz ist
schon da dfb präsidenten fritz keller
haben wir gesehen der deutschland achter
der in jan frodeno rodlerin natalie
geisenberger und und und ja also das
volle programm und wir können ihnen auch
sagen wir haben diverse überraschungen
für die siegerinnen und sieger parat
verraten wird natürlich überhaupt nichts
an dieser stelle so viel vielleicht dass
es ein denkbares kopf an kopf rennen bei
den männern zwischen dem ersten und
zweiten platz war
foto finish also einschalten lohnt sich
dankeschön 22.15 kopf-an-kopf grüne
jetzt scheint zurzeit wer gewonnen hat
grübel noch ein bisschen weiter und
setzt dann gleich sehen ich weiß es
nicht und ich wir gucken dann für den 18
vielen dank dann gucke ich hier auf
diesen zettel oder steht das wetter und
das ist morgen im nordwesten so etwas
regen sonne gibt es vor allem im süden
das ganze bei maximalen temperaturen von
sechs bis zehn grad im norden und 9 bis
14 grad im süden und die kommenden tage
werden meist trocken und sehr mild
nachher bei uns im programm das heute
journal 21 uhr 45 im gespräch ein
deutscher klimaforscher wie weiter nach
der konferenz in madrid morgen freut
sich an dieser stelle petra gerster auf
sie im namen von team 19 danke für ihr
interesse